claudia meyer
haben
ich schreibe morgen machte das war mir
ganz sicher wissen worum geht's
noch zehn minuten youtube womöglich
nicht
17 uhr schon ich sitze da noch keine
stunde dran
das hat mir so schnell scheiß jetzt mal
anfangen damit ich auch gar nicht erst
versuchen komme es so und hier mache ich
zumindest den bildschirm aus
einfach ignorieren
das kann es jetzt echt nicht sein oder
alter macht den schalter ganz aus ich
bin ich jetzt schon wieder hier dran
gekommen
doch jetzt reicht es mir
ohne scheiß leute kennt ihr diese
situation wenn ja was noch nach oben da
teilt ist wieder auf facebook auf ins
netz april nicht vergessen kommentar
schreiben und so weiter
nein spaß sollte also nach oben könnt
ihr natürlich gerne gehen also ich halte
solche fallen und dass wir vielleicht
noch mal so was wollt schreibt die
kommentare an sitzen und hier oben
rechts es weiter mit meinem video das
war mädchen vs jung in einer beziehung
trifft auf jeden fall aber wirklich
freuen ansonst abonniert vergessen ob
ich sie zu verpassen wir sehen uns
nächsten mittwoch wieder online shop